we're sad to report tonight that the
venerable new york post
newspaper crossed the line this week
they wrote a story revealing that one of
the founders of the sacred blm
movement has in fact spent millions of
dollars on
four high-end homes just in the united
states and that's not allowed
embarrassing the leader of blm just for
being greedy please stop
new york post that was facebook's
position
facebook is now blocking the new york
post reporting we just tried to share it
on facebook and we got a message you
can't share this link because it goes
against our community standards
those standards include flacking for
every left-wing activist group in
america
we ask facebook and they give us this
statement quote this content was removed
for violating our privacy and personal
information policies
by the way pictures of the blm houses
were everywhere real estate blogs wrote
about them they're not blocked
facebook said the story could help
people identify the blm founders
personal residence
right we can promise you they don't
extend that courtesy to others in the
public eye
in recent days twitter has also censored
posts from the founder of project
veritas james o'keefe
and a frequent guest on this program
shockingly jason whitlock
so the censorship is just intensifying
is anyone noticing this or doing
anything about it ned ryan notices
he's the ceo of american majority he
joins us tonight ned so
they've they silenced trump when he was
still president like you know trump's
not allowed to talk
still but they didn't stop there it
turns out they like
silenced everyone not just who voted for
trump but anyone who
in any way goes against the the regime
orthodoxy
when does this end if ever when
republicans and conservatives get
righteous on this issue and a lot of
them are conflicted on a tucker i mean
you look back at the 2020 elections
when republican house leadership is
taking maxed out contributions from
google but even more so
members of the house freedom caucus are
taking maxed out contributions from
google
conservative organizations in dc are
taking money from the tech
giants to promote and run the party line
for the tech companies
until we change until we say no more and
it really is
it's a litmus test for me now tucker do
you renounce satan in all of his evil
works
do you renounce big tech and all of
their evil works their censorship their
their meddling in the free flow of
information quite frankly they're
meddling in free and fair elections with
zuckerberg center for tech and civic
life
until republicans and conservatives can
get it in their heads
that when monopolies dominate a
marketplace you don't have free market
capitalism
we have to break monopolies it's
actually republican tradition and also
stop mistaking corporatism for
capitalism when you have these big
corporations that are working hand in
glove with big government
that's not capitalism that's that's big
crony capital uh
corporatism and it's doing working on
behalf of big government quite frankly
democrats and establishment republicans
love this tucker you know why
they don't have to shred the bill of
rights into a full frontal assault upon
our basic human rights
they can step out of the way and let the
corporations do their dirty work for
them
as libertarians and others are going oh
we can't touch them because they're
private corporations absurd and
ridiculous
so everyone in the country is watching
this
and this is discrediting market
capitalism because it's not actually
marking capitalism it's monopoly
capitalism it's crushing people right so
when we get socialism in a couple years
and
totally wreck the country will anyone be
honest enough to acknowledge this is why
well this is the problem i mean this is
why republicans and conservatives need
to get righteous and understand the
difference between the corporatism and
capitalism
because people do conflate them and
they're going to look at this behavior
and say well this this is capitalism i
will say this the right approach to this
talk is going to take place at the state
level when
26 other republican governors do the
exact same thing that ron desantis is
doing and taking a strong stance on big
tech
we'll see reform at the state level
probably first before anything in d.c
crush these people immediately i agree
that's right ned thank you so much